des résidents de Rouyn-Noranda
attendaient de pied ferme le Ministre
Benoît charrette c'est que les risques
associés à l'arsenic dégagés par la
fonderie Horn ont de quoi inquiéter
retard neuro-développementaux chez le
foetus et l'enfant cancer du poumon et
autres maladies les révélations récentes
ont réveillé les craintes et soulevez
bien des angoisses moi j'ai toujours dit
que j'allais revenir m'établir à une
randogue j'en ai jamais douté jusqu'à il
y a quelques mois je trouve ça
préoccupant je suis en colère faut que
ça bouge maintenant si il dit que il
descend la norme mais j'ai pas envie
plus longtemps des groupes de citoyens
demandaient des cibles ambitieuses au
gouvernement notamment de baisser le
plafond d'émission d'arsenic à 15
nanogrammes par mètre cube d'air d'ici
la prochaine année c'est une cible
intermédiaire on s'entend parce que à ce
niveau là on ne protège pas contre les
cancers le ministre donne pourtant
jusqu'à 5 ans à la fonderie orn pour
atteindre cet objectif et rien de précis
concernant la teinte de la québécoise de
3 nanogrammes dans le quartier
Notre-Dame près de la fonderie je
m'attends à ce que la fonderie nous
présente dans les prochains jours ou à
tout le monde plus rapidement possible
un plan qui va nous permettre
d'atteindre les 15 nanogrammes dans un
premier temps mais également une vision
à plus long terme pour atteindre le 3 un
anagramme la fonderie avec couverture
les orientations présentées aujourd'hui
et s'engage à atteindre les objectifs
les plus ambitieux les groupes de
citoyens qui ont rencontré le ministre
sont pourtant déçus on était découragé
les quatre on pleurait dans l'ascenseur
on s'est pris dans les bras puis on
s'attendait vraiment on s'attendait
peut-être pas à des miracles mais on
s'attendait quand même à mieux que ça ce
qu'on entend c'est que on va être encore
pour plusieurs années bien au-delà de 15
monogrammes par mètre cube et cette
cible là elle était spécifiquement
sécuritaire pour les populations
vulnérables donc on a spécifiquement
mentionné les bébés à naître les mamans
enceintes les jeunes enfants restent à
voir aussi avec la santé publique afin
de savoir c'est quoi les les risques
pour la santé de nos gens selon les
cibles intermédiaires qui seront
définies Québec émettra bientôt ces
directives à la fonderie 1 après des
consultations publiques des amendes ou
des injonctions pour efforcer la lumière
Glenn à respecter ses objectifs ici les
alarmes Radio-Canada Rouyn-Noranda